but then I met this guy through this
dating app we just had a connection and
he happened to be flying the next day to
South Africa after talking for a little
bit it sounds crazy but he bought me a
ticket and I flew out
but he actually didn't turn out to be
the greatest he was actually not a good
guy so I left in the middle tonight I
went out to the bar he started drinking
met some girls and you know then I saw a
cute bartender behind the bar and he
said his name was in gym dancing and
smiling and I went home with him that
night
and I didn't leave the side here she
comes I'm sending documentary all the
way from Camp space South Africa saying
that I've stayed there for almost two
months before I came back to the stage
hello Sonia I just like to say that I'm
gonna miss you a lot like a lot a lot
like a lot like really a lot not this
much like that much sinja and I were
living a long-distance relationship
Sonia yeah so hard it was really hard
so I packed up my stuff then I flew
right back
Laurie back to South Africa
[Music]